et pour en parler nous sommes avec
aimerait comme on vit l'écrivain et
soutien de toulenne assange
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en direct sur arte france
alors malgré le confinement on voit bien
les soutiens de dieu la nation sont
toujours mobilisé cela fait un an qu'il
a été arrêté à l'ambassade d'équateur à
londres et quel bilan pouvez vous faire
sur cette année oui il serait bon qu'on
m'ait l'occasion de il est bon de voir
la question qu'on avait de julian
assange à toutes les occasions sont
bonnes mais en instance ya pas de raison
de fêter un an de keenan après le
kidnapping et un an de belmarsh par
exemple c'est vrai que le 5 avril
dernier on y avait le jalon des 10 ans
de la vidéo que meurtre collatéral qui
avait constitué un apport considérable
de wikileaks au journalisme ce qu'elle
montre est un crime de guerre étasuniens
en direct donc c'est vrai qu'on aimerait
mieux marquer le coup avec des
événements qu'on pourrait qu'on pourrait
célébrer et pas seulement commémorer
mais bon il est évident que cette
mobilisation autour de jehanne assange
est un test et d'ailleurs qui est qui
est très positif pour vérifier qu'on ne
profite pas complètement de l'épidémie
pour détruire le peu qui reste de nos
libertés démocratiques et vérifier que
les gens sont pas si groggy par les
fêtes stupeur de l'épidémie sur le le
confinement bien sûr c'est une mesure
destinée à ralentir le nombre de malades
traités en hôpitaux mais ça pas vocation
à durer à condition qu'on se donne les
moyens de soigner de protéger de tester
les populations parce que là en ce
moment il est évident que julian assange
et la met à mort la métaphore même deux
de ces espèces de réduction du citoyen
en particulier en fait il est il était
un symbole du droit mal à l'information
et ils représentent une part de
nous-mêmes la forme ancienne de
l'humaine condition
et de ce point de vue là c'est il est
très important que l'opinion se
mobilisent pour le pour le pour le
défendre plus que jamais et a fortiori
dans ces conditions on vient de le dire
la justice britannique a refusé de
libérer julian assange malgré une santé
très fragile mais également les risques
de contamination au coronavirus à la
prison de belmarsh quel sentiment vous
laisse cette décision oui ce que je
voudrais dire c'est un sentiment
évidemment d'amertume parce que c'est
vrai que d'ailleurs il ya pas seulement
un prisonnier à belmarsh selon joris van
smith si on aurait 2 de deux prisonniers
qui serait mort à belle marche mais ce
que je voulais dire c'est qu'en lançant
l'alerté sur les risques que gianna
serge demers du cor unum virus il faut
pas non plus habitué l'opinion à cette
idée parce que on peut émettre
il faut on peut pas émettre l'idée de ce
risque sans dire que ce sera un scandale
absolu pour la grande bretagne
parce que je rappelle quand même qu'il a
48 ans c'est à dire que non
statistiquement il n'y a aucune raison
qui qui qui qui meurent de ce ce virus
il est bien traité c'est à dire on a peu
de risque d'en mourir à cet âge ma
condition qu'on soit bien traitée en cas
de difficultés respiratoires cdmt
fragile son état psychologique et
physique dans quel état justement est-il
aujourd'hui
maintenant c'est vrai qu'il est un
rapport de 60 médecins c'est surtout sur
des conditions de détresse psychique je
pense qu'ils ont qu'ils ont assisté il
n'y a pas de difficultés respiratoires
particulière tout ce que je veux dire
c'est que ce serait un scandale absolu
pour la grande bretagne de de laisser
mourir du cancer virus qu'il n'espère
pas se sortir de cette situation-là
je rappelle quand même que nice nézet
rapport de l'onu avec la solution suisse
parce que grand conseil de genève avait
porté un immense majorité pour pour
obtenir un visa humanitaire
hocan assange il avait dit que cette
socialiste cette solution suscite une
solution on aura d'ailleurs je rappelle
que le parlement autrichien a remporté
également selon son soutien à julian
assange
il ya des solutions honorable de sortie
de crise en fait pour y compris pour que
la grande bretagne ne perde pas la face
mais s'il espère le faire disparaître
dans ces conditions à sous prétexte de
coronavirus c'est un scandale absolu
jeudi c'est la même chose d'ailleurs
pour la france avec notre le plus vieux
prisonnier politique qui est georges
ibrahim abdallah ça fait trente quatre
ans qu'il est qu'il est en prison nelson
mandela s'était 27 mai georges ibrahim
abdallah 69 ans cette année donc
lui aussi une relation risque signer si
rien n'est fait pour le port pour le
libérer enfin on va avoir un véritable
scandale politique à la je peux vous
dire que les gens sont plus gros guide
de ceux de ce confinement là maintenant
l'opinion se mobilisent et compris à la
faveur du confinement les gens plus de
temps pour réfléchir à ces à ces
questions là se poser et se poser des
questions sur l'ensemble en fait de nos
de nos libertés démocratiques
j'appelle aussi que la lan nhs en prison
à la prison de belmarsh à la normale nhs
national health service c'est le système
de santé britannique
donc c'est pas c'est pas la discrétion
de la prison le système de soins et le
bellemare je sais pas a priori c'est pas
les baumettes c'était une situation de
très haute sécurité je parle des
baumettes parce que c'est une déprime
faisons de france donc temps d'en haut
il n'y a aucune raison qu'ils soient pas
bien traités alors on apprend qu'il est
qu'il fait sa promenade disons tous les
tout d'une demi heure par jour
encombrée de détenus alors que
normalement il est censé de tenir des
sources et des tas bon toutou tout cela
et tout ça est extrêmement opaque et
s'ajoute à cela le fait qu'on puisse
plus justement circuler se rendre nous
mêmes en allons dans ce monde à londres
sur place très bien en tout cas merci
beaucoup
eric montville d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
écrivain et soutien de julian assange